bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions qui vous éclaire sur les
intentions pas toujours louables des
dirigeants de notre planète
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'euro numérique 1 la dernière
idée de madame lagarde
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses caches euros numérique ce terme
ne vous dit peut-être rien mais vous
risquez add on entendre beaucoup parler
ces prochains mois en quoi consiste ce
projet initié à part la banque centrale
européenne
quels seront les contours de cette
nouvelle monnaie numérique et est ce une
bonne idée
ce sont les questions auxquelles on
tentera de répondre dans cette émission
et pour cela en deuxième partie nous
serons avec fabrice epelboin enseignant
à sciences po et spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux
alors face à l'essor des monnaies
virtuelles comme le bitcoin ou encore la
livre à la monnaie à de facebook la
banque centrale européenne elle aussi a
décidé de se tailler la part du lion
pour l'instant l'euro numérique est
encore à l'état de projet il pourrait
voir le jour d'ici trois à quatre ans la
bce a d'ailleurs lancé une grande
consultation auprès des citoyens
européens pour avoir leur avis sur ce
projet alors à quoi pourrait ressembler
leur au numérique qui éléments de
réponse avec le tiroir cash d'antoine
basse
l'euro numérique c'est la nouvelle idée
de christine lagarde et de la banque
centrale européenne une monnaie purement
virtuelle qui pourraient être utilisés
par vous comme par mois via notre
smartphone
quelle différence avec les euros sur
votre compte en banque
et bien déjà les transactions seront
plus rapides voire instantanée et ne
nécessiteront aucun règlements
interbancaires comme c'est le cas
actuellement
plus surprenant encore 7 euros numérique
permettrait à la bce de voir ces
politiques monétaires directement
parvenir aux citoyens et se passer
totalement des banques privées tour
ainsi selon les mots de la bce stimuler
directement la consommation des ménages
et des investissements des entreprises
en clair impossible bouleversements à
venir de la monnaie accélérée notamment
par le cos vide 19 oui encore lui
puisqu'il a fortement stimulé les
paiements sans contact et affaiblit
encore le vieil argent liquide stimuler
également par l'essor de plus en plus de
modèles numériques comme la libre à de
facebook ou les projets d'autres états
comme celui de la chine ou des états
unis
en clair la bce ne voulait tout
simplement pas se retrouver sur la
touche
reste plusieurs problèmes qui se posent
la sécurité d'abord même si la bce
affirme qu'elle utiliserait un système
blocs shane réputée inviolable également
une possible suite des épargnants des
banques privées enfin un problème de
respect de la vie privée face à une
hégémonie renforcée d'une bce qui
pourrait tracer toutes les transactions
que vous pourriez effectué à olivier
reconnaît un petit peu votre avis sur
les monnaies virtuelles sans chercher à
savoir pour l'instant si c'est si c'est
une bonne ou une mauvaise idée pourquoi
selon vous la bce a décidé d'initier ce
projet pour deux choses qui ont été
dites d'ailleurs dans le tiroir cache la
première c'est que beaucoup ontanon ces
mêmes de grandes entreprises et et vous
rendez compte que évidemment aucun état
ne peut accepter qu'une qu'une
entreprise et met sa monnaie
et donc la libre à ça a été le ca a été
le signal d'alarmé
c'est tous les ce et tous les grands
argentiers du monde donc il n'est pas
étonnant que la bce
suivent le mouvement la deuxième raison
et c'est bien ça qui est inquiétant
c'est que encore une fois on cherche à
mettre la main sur toutes les
informations que vous pourrez fournir
donc c'est ça avec eux on dit souvent
quand le service est gratuit c'est vous
le produit est bien nous sommes
considérés comme des produits et donc il
faut avoir le maximum d'informations
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on va profiter
du coc vide et on va profiter aussi
d'ailleurs
ça a déjà commencé avec les certaines
déclarations de bruno le maire on va
essayer de mettre sur le le dos de la
protection contre le terrorisme ex
paiera le fait de supprimer le cash est
virtuel et donc permettre d'avoir
absolument toutes les informations et
que rien ne leur échappe pourtant validé
bce précise que cet euro numérique n'a
pas vocation à remplacer le cash mais
non mais bien sûr ils vont pas vous le
dire c'est comme la dernière fois
monsieur macron qui nous disait que le
lille était prêt pour la 2eme gbagbo on
voit comment il a été prêt donc on est
on est évidemment on avance masqué quand
on est une banque centrale
on va pas vous annoncer dès le départ
que c'est pour annuler le le cache
évidemment que c'est quelque chose qui
est dans leur volonté
pourquoi parce que ça leur échappe parce
qu'ils ne savent pas ce que vous en
faites
et ça ça les dérange vraiment d'un
pardon l'enjeu concrètement pour la bce
s'est pas rester à la traîne face aux
gars face à face ou souhaitant rester à
la traîne et puis je vous dise et c'est
ça s'inscrit dans un dans un mouvement
qui est là depuis déjà plusieurs années
qui est de d'avoir le plus de
renseignements de ce que vous faites
pour vous utilisez comme un produit
c'est tout et donc ça on le sait depuis
longtemps aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez
plus faire quoi que ce soit sans que
votre banque qui a tous vos relevés donc
qui sait absolument tout ce que vous
faites tout ce que vous achetez etc et
qui vont vendre ces données c'est une
évidence
justement olivier on va voir tout cela
on passe à la deuxième partie de cette
émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec fabrice epelboin bonjour fabrice
est pas le brand vous êtes enseignant à
sciences po et spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux bienvenue chez dans ces caches
bon jour pour commencer votre avis sur
cette idée de la de la bce de créer un
euro numérique
fabrice epelboin alors d'abord faut
souligner qu effectivement olivier a
parfaitement raison l'abonné c'est déjà
du numérique et ça fait huit ans que ces
numérique
on va changer d' approche dans la façon
d'utiliser le numérique on passe d'un
système qui pour faire très simple est
une espèce de bases de données ou plus
exactement une multitude de base de
données de banques centrales qui
échangent des données entre elles à une
base de données décentralisée et
l'essence de la blocs chaîne sert que
tout ça sera totalement fasciné fiable
parfaitement sécurisée parce que ça fait
un bout de temps déjà on utilisa blog
shane donc s'il y avait des problèmes de
sécurité on s'en serait aperçu il ya
tout un tas de problèmes mais là dessus
c'est solide et puis on va plonger dans
cet univers où finalement on n'échange
plus démodé mais on échange des choses
dans des walt est donc il ya un usage
qui effectivement est très très lourd
c'est pas demain la veille qu'on va
acheter une baguette avec un voile est
ancrée qd au modem mais c'est peut-être
après demain et puis par ailleurs je
note quand même que ça provoque une
désintermédiation entre le citoyen et la
banque centrale qui permet effectivement
d'envisager des choses comme le
l'hélicoptère monnaie ou le revenu
universel de façon directe entre les
banques centrales et des citoyens
européens ce que ne permet pas pour
l'instant le système financier tel point
là donc ça vous des possibilités mais en
même temps on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
penser que d'une part la blocs chaîne et
l'idée décrypte monnaie sur la bloquer
n'a pas vraiment été imaginé pour ça au
contraire ça plutôt été imaginé comme
une alternative à ça
et que l'alternative se voulait
expérimenter d'autres formes de monnaies
typiquement la masse monétaire défini
d'avant ce qu'est l'essence du pop du
licol où tout un tas d'autres
expérimentations qui consiste à mettre
hors jeu
le système financier actuel donc là on a
une récupération par le système
financier et les banques sans pales qui
n'est pas rien dans cette aile financier
qui à la base me semble quand même une
appréhension du problème bien plus
intelligente que n'ont fait il ya déjà
20 ans les maisons de disques quand les
ont été confrontés au peer-to-peer et au
mp3 est fondamentalement c'est ce même
type de description on est dans une
description qui est technologiquement
parlant est tout à fait comparable à
l'arrivée du peer-to-peer c'est à dire
la disparition de la fonction
distribution dans l'économie de la
musique qui a été réparti par tout un
chacun chaque personne qui fait du
peer-to-peer participent à la
distribution des fichiers qu'ils
partagent une là on a ce type de distri
de distribution fondamental dans
l'essence du système financier actuel
j'ai peur que d'une façon générale les
banques centrales n'est pas vraiment le
choix que de mettre timidement un pied
dans le dans le bain pour participer à
tout ça sinon elle risque d'être
totalement exclue de quelque chose qui
ne va peut-être prendre le relais d'un
certain financiers qui pourraient
présenter des signes de défaillance
alors leur au numérique nous dit la bce
existerait donc parallèlement aux
espèces sans les remplacer les européens
auraient anciens là un choix élargi et
d'instruments et pourrait effectuer
leurs paiements plus facilement ce qui
renforcerait l'inclusion financière
concrètement quelle différence avec les
cryptologues c'est quoi la plus grosse
différence avec les crypto monnaie qui
existent déjà comme par exemple le
bitcoin en dehors du fait que votre
boulanger va accepter de de l'eau et pas
des victoires n'y a pas de différence à
ce stade c'est des voilettes et un
processus qui est quand même très
compliqué pour acheter un
on sait c'est pas demain la veille que
ma mère achète pas ses baguettes avec
need me cogne ni de du crypto euros
cessé il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup de
progrès à faire mais il n'est pas
interdit de penser que si on distribue
un revenu universel à tous les citoyens
français mais il faut qu'ils apprennent
à utiliser un wallet et de la crypte
monnaie ils vont s'y mettre c'est ça
peut être une façon d'imposer ce type de
technologie dans les foyers mais ça
prend beaucoup de temps oui je vous
entends des a rigolé
à cette citation est des dégâts la bce
s'est évidemment ils avancent masqués
ils vont pas vous dire dès le départ on
fait ça pour supprimer le cash et c'est
quand même bien leurs idées et puis la
deuxième idée c'est quand même de
récupérer le pourquoi les gens sont
allés dans le dans le bitcoin et dans
d'autres crypto monnaie y sont allés
parce que justement il avait
l'impression d'échapper à l'état
d'échapper à quelque chose qui ne sur
lesquelles il n'avait plus aucun
contrôle qui était la banque centrale où
les banques centrales plutôt devenu
totalement folle et qui simple qui
s'amusait à imprimer des billets comme
s'il en pleuvait donc ils sont allés
vers quelque chose qui leur paraissait
plus sécurisé et qu'on ne pouvait pas
multiplier que qui avait une montant de
départ 21 millions froid pour le bitcoin
est et qui en auraient jamais un de plus
et donc ils sont allés là dessus pour
répondre à ce que faisait la banque
centrale aujourd'hui qu'est ce que fait
la banque centrale
elle récupère le système systèmes
technologiques et elle se l'approprient
parce que en fait qui va contrôler cet
euro numérique c'est la banque centrale
s'est pas où il ose donc c'est elle qui
flatte fixer les règles
donc elle pour aller changer quand elle
le voudra donc on est on est on était
sorti fin beaucoup étaient sortis de ce
système là pour aller se réfugier
alors certains sur des actifs physiques
comme lors d'autres sur des actifs
numériques comme le beacon et puis bah
la banque centrale essaie de rattraper
le coup et de présenter ça comme une
évolution extraordinaire en fait elle
cherche à reprendre la main et donc à
contrôler une nouvelle monnaie mais
c'est toujours elle qui la contrôlera
c'est toujours elle qui en fera ce
qu'elle voudra et donc ça ne change
strictement rien à ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est à dire le jour où
le voudra gonfler la masse d'euros
numérique 2x est bien le fera donc ça ne
change strictement rien par rapport à ce
qui à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui alors
peut-être que ça changera c'est à dire
que ça lui permettra de renvoyer en
effet de l'hélicoptère monnaie sûre sur
les ménages
mais aujourd'hui monsieur trump l'a fait
en envoyant un chèque à tous les
américains si vous voulez donc il n'y a
rien de nouveau sous le soleil peut le
faire déjà sans ce sans passer forcément
par la blocs shine blocs chaîne je
dirais c'est une une façon de vendre
c'est une façon de rendre la chose mais
si on va marquer une courte pause et on
revient dans un instant bienvenue dans
ces caches si vous nous rejoignez au
sommaire l'euro numérique avec fabrice
epelboin enseignant à sciences po et
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
fabrice epelboin est ce que cette
monnaie virtuelle européenne elle
pourrait concurrencer apparaître des
modèles comme le décrypte monnaie comme
le bitcoin ou comme les monnaies des
gaffes a par exemple
non pas du tout le beacon absolument pas
le milton c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement spéculative de très
volatile cc c'est quelque chose qui qui
nécessitent d'être d'avoir un esprit de
traders de d'être en permanence en train
de regarder son portefeuille pour
éventuellement se faire de mouvement une
à l'euro c'est quelque chose que vous
avez sur votre compte en banque
n'oublier aucune avait pour l'instant
absolument aucun doute sur la valeur de
l'euro demain matin et ni même après
demain le dicton c'est une jeunesse
responsable de tes dires moi j'ai j'ai
eu sur la valeur non disons à court
terme on peut imaginer que quand même on
reste encore dans une heure mais c'est
mais tu as tout à fait raison c'est on
va vers des zones inconnues
toujours est il que si vous aussi vous
avez une patronne aujourd'hui vous
regardez avec anxiété votre portefeuille
tous les matins exactement je me suis
vous aviez fait des paris en bourse
extrêmement spéculatifs
c'est pas du tout le cas pour votre
compte en banque au mortier sur votre
banque traditionnelle
en fait la principale différence c'est
que l'euro numérique
spéculation cc c'est vraiment une bonne
à dire la situation tout cas il ya de la
spéculation sur l'euro mais avec avec
des impacts sur la variabilité de la
valeur de l'euro qui seront assez
négligeable alors que sur le bitcoin cad
masse monétaire comme ridicules par
rapport à l'euro le moindre mouvement
peut provoquer des variations extrêmes
de cours donc le l'euro c'est dans
l'univers décrit deux modèles le rose
c'est la style qu une ultime
l'astag olten cd monnaie numérique comme
le beacon mais dont le but
là pour le coup est d'avoir une valeur
la plus stable possible et c'est démodé
qui vont servir de refuge
entre des opérations spéculatives ou
juste pour stocker un capital disponible
dort chez des gens qui la plupart du
temps ce sont donc amiens une optique
totalement ce que tu vas t'il avec une
multitude de criquetot beaudet qui
chacun à un an leur historique par
petite histoire leur variabilité leur
pique leurs bulles spéculatives
si l'euro arrive dans cet univers là ça
va être l'un des principaux stephen
quake saab est l'endroit où après avoir
fait un bon coup sûr le bitcoin dont je
me dis que peut-être que c'est que ça
devient très risqué qu'il faut vendre
elle va reconvertir que pickton en
crypto euros il y aura françois blanc un
crypto dollars et il existe dès à
présent des crypto or c'est à dire
grosso modo des modèles numériques qui
sont indexées sur de l'or et qui me
permettent de stocker du patrimoine en
or ce qui est quelque chose là encore de
relativement stable donc le fait que
l'euro arrive dans cet univers là il va
y trouver une place naturelle qui est
une monnaie de mener de réfugié derrière
sa place dans le système financier
international et il y va du coup
permettre un retour parce que là les
problèmes des gens qui se lancent dans
cette spéculation mais le clip de
baudets et c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement couronne en milieu des
start-up même s'ils représentent pas
grand monde en france mais aujourd'hui
la plupart des jeunes entrepreneurs que
vous allez trouver la station f spécule
sur de la crise le mot n'est exactement
comme moi quand j'avais la vingtaine que
c'était l'histoire de la première bulle
internet dans les années 90 et que tout
le monde avait des actions tout le monde
découvrait la bourse et spéculer sur
tout et n'importe quoi peut que
s'apportent internet dans ce type ont un
air de près dans cette situation le
problème c'est que quand j'ai commencé à
boire à un certain patrimoine investi en
clinique tôt j'échappe totalement à
l'euro dollar je suis sorti je suis dans
cet univers alternatif
et là où la démarche de la banque
centrale et brest des banques centrales
en général je doute que l'europe sur la
seule à être dans cette démarche est
finalement assez intelligent c'est que
plutôt que de lutter contre cette
alternative n'est d'internet
encore une fois comme l'ont fait les
maisons 10 face au peer-to-peer et ils
ont plutôt tendance à faire avec et on a
vu ça avec des grandes banques
américaines
dans un premier temps avec un discours
extrêmement négatif sur le beacon et qui
ensuite ont ouvert des produits
spéculatifs à des stations leurs clients
basé sur le big one donc c'est à la fois
une démarche d'une certaine modestie
face aux distributions technologique je
pense que les gens de la haute finance
ont appris que lutter contre ça c'était
probablement perdu d avance et en même
temps il avance avec quelque chose qui
est quand même préservé et non simple
totalement centralisée avec évidemment
une ambition de surveiller ce qui se
passe de comprendre ce qui se passe et
de façon d'en faire la chasse à tout un
tas de choses
est ce que c'est cette voie là qui va
aller vers la fin prévue près 10 de du
papier voyez ça me paraît pas être la
meilleure façon de tuer papiers monnaies
je moi je vous réponde ans quand même à
essayer de comprendre comment le virus
se transmet à travers le patrimoine et
je suis sûr qu'il ya moyen de
transmettre le virus à part le mener de
façon à provoquer une peur et augmenter
les taux du paiement sans contact qui a
déjà été fait on peut payer jusqu'à 50
50 euros sans contact donc c'est clair
que le papier monnaie
on pense est condamné à terme ça peut
être un coup supplémentaire je pense pas
que ce sera le coup fatal
je pensais avoir une multitude de coups
qui petit à petit vous rendre le le
papier monnaie
de plus en plus inutilisables et que
inéluctablement arrive un moment où ça
sera ça aura totalement disparu
olivier avec 7 euros numérique la bce
donc horaires d'accès direct aux
citoyens elle espère jeu suit ce cumul
est directement la consommation des
ménages ou les investissements des
entreprises
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de cet
outil pour stimuler la consommation des
ménages
non c'est ce que je vous disais à
l'instant c'est à dire que vous avez eue
vous avez eu monsieur tron qui l'a fait
vous aviez eu d'ailleurs
monsieur bush qui l'avait fait il ya
déjà un moment donc c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau il a envoyé un
chèque
donc il n'y a absolument pas besoin
aujourd'hui de mettre en place ce
système là pour avoir accès aux comptes
des ménages
il suffit il suffit simplement de
d'envoyer un chèque à tout le monde donc
si on veut vraiment faire de
l'hélicoptère monnaie on n'a aucun
besoin de ce système
alors maintenant vous allez bien oui ça
sera ça sera plus rapide oui ce sera
plus rapide
et alors c'est pas que plus rapide il y
aura pas besoin des banques oui la danse
on est d'accord mais mais ceci dit c'est
quelque chose qui a déjà été fait sans
sens le le ring louise shine est bon
donc tu es encaissé la bce ne se cache
pas derrière ça en disant on ne peut pas
le faire parce qu'on n'a pas le blocage
n
non s'il voulait le faire ils le
feraient je pense d'ailleurs que quand
même quelque part c'est ces luttes quoi
si vous voulez c'est à dire d'avoir
finalement une une bonne armée qui
travaillent tous pour l'état qui est
dans la main de l'état qui vous donnera
votre pitance quotidienne et et
peut-être que c'est le le modèle dont
rêve
nos dirigeants actuels donc je suis pas
sûr que ça soit le modèle qu'il fasse
rêver tout le monde dans le monde
olivier vous parliez des banques
injustement avec leur numérique ces
banques de la zone euro elles pourraient
elles sont en danger
de toute façon vous savez les bords les
boks a fait un moment qu elles sont en
danger en danger de mort et elle
pourrait se retrouver clairement
fragilisés abs mais elles sont déjà
fragilisés c'est pas le c'est pas le
sujet le sait pas c'est pas ça qui va
les fragiliser aujourd'hui la plupart
des banques sont des entreprises zombies
on sait on sait qu'il va y avoir des
des dégâts énormes vous avez quelques
banques qui sont dans un état on va dire
moins pire que les autres et qui vont
probablement récupérer les cadavres à la
fin donc voila vous aurez en effet une
concentration des banques
et puis pourquoi pas une concentration
suprême c'est à dire qu'il y en ait plus
qu'une qui soit la banque centrale
mais je rappelle que c'est au départ
c'est quand même pas son son son modèle
la banque centrale c'est la banque des
banques c'est pas la banque la seule
banque donc je ne sais pas si les autres
pays vont marcher dans le même dans la
même direction est
et donc voilà je pense que le système
bancaire de toute façon il est en grande
partie mort depuis
mais ça ça date depuis 2008 on a on en
n'est jamais sorti de cette histoire
donc on a des créances qui vont être
encore plus si recouvrables qu'avant
puisque le taux de défaut va exploser
avec les confinements et et autres et
avec une récession monumental donc
figurez-vous louis les banques sont déjà
en danger et je pense que les les
tribulations de madame lagarde ne vont
pas changer grand chose
fabrice epelboin injuste pour terminer
un mot sur le respect de la vie privée
olivier a évoqué tout à l'heure la
commercialisation à des données la bce
de son côté assure qu'il n'y en aura pas
est ce que c'est vraiment ça peut
vraiment être le cas la bce pourrait
elle aussi tracer toutes les
transactions ou est-ce que de toute
façon aujourd'hui plus rien n'est
vraiment privé alors vos transactions
actuelles avec votre carte bleue elles
sont déjà vendus avec google et facebook
c'est déjà le cas c'est comme ça que
google et facebook et tout un tas
d'autres alimente des profils pour
anticiper vos besoins anticiper vos
désirs on sait c'était beau à vos
réflexions et et y parer ou en tirer
profit
ça c'est déjà le cas par contre là où il
faut être très clair avec la bloque
l'accès que l'essence d'un budget c'est
d'être une information publique est
disponible à tous donc
informations elles seront à disposition
de qui n'en peut pour être traité et en
sortir je ne sais quoi il y aura une
très vaste et qui sera garanti par le
fait que les wallet que je nos
portefeuilles dans 15 mai new krypton
monnaie ne sont pas nominatifs et que la
banque centrale
elle aura des relations dominati ventre
les voilà était donc la banque centrale
tu sauras mais les personnes qui
pourront tout un chacun chacun d'entre
nous peut lire ce qui se passe dans
n'importe quel objet ça c'est une donnée
publique
merci beaucoup à fabrice epelboin
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant à sciences po et spécialiste
des réseaux sociaux olivier nous on
continue avec les questions cash et
comme chaque semaine olivier vous
répondez aux questions que vous posent
les internautes et on commence tout de
suite avec celle de sébastien robin
bonjour olivier quelles sont les banques
les plus en risque les banques suisses
sont elles moins en risque que les
banques françaises
oui alors on l'a déjà dit si plusieurs
fois une simplement par leur leur modèle
si vous voulez c'est à dire qu'une
langue française c'est une banque qui
est généraliste qui fait donc tous les
métiers et qui étend en leverage c'est à
dire qu'il est temps en effet de levier
qui est des effets de levier qui sont
juste ahurissant donc elles sont en
risque elles prêtent de l'argent aussi
et donc vous quand vous prêtez de
l'argent vous avez un risque on ne vous
le rende pas et surtout dans des phases
comme actuellement avec avec une crise
économique majeure
il ya plein d'entreprises qui vont être
en difficulté qui ne pourront pas
rembourser leurs prêts et donc les
banques sont en son temps risque quand
vous avez une banque privée suisse
alors je vous parle pas du ps ou credit
suisse qui fonctionne exactement comme
une société générale ou une bmp mais
quand vous avez des vraies banques
privées suisses elle ne vous prêtent pas
d'argent parce que c'est pas leur métier
elles ne font que gérer votre argent
c'est tout et donc vous avez évidemment
un moindre risque à bien moindre risque
parce que elles ne font pas le même
métier tout simplement merci à l'idée
pour cette explication une caisse
à présent de frenchy en rapport avec les
missions sur les épargnants et la
facture du colis de 19
très bien alors on sort d'urgence nos
économies a de l'assurance vie de nos
comptes bancaires de l'immobilier on
transforme tout ça en billets sans
compter l'hyperinflation qui pourrait
les réduire en cendres un crypto monnaie
qui peuvent elles aussi devenir illégal
ou encore être perdu ou volé donc c'est
bien d'alerté mais que doit-on faire
concrètement
alors là 10 10 fois enfin je jeu il
faudrait que les gens avant de poser des
questions écoute l'émission ça serait
mieux parce que ça leur permettrait de
poser des questions plus plus
intéressante
on leur a dit ce qu'il fallait faire
c'est à dire que en effet il faut pas
laisser son argent dans une banque parce
que la banque
à ce moment là vous le prendre à un
moment ou un autre donc vous devez
sortir je sais pas pourquoi il parle du
mobilier
en effet moi je pense que l'immobilier
en tout cas certains immobiliers vont
aller sur une pente descendante mais on
n'a jamais dit de vendre en
précipitations sont immobilier est là la
dernière chose c'est que non il faut pas
le transformer en biais et mettre ça
dans son coffre
parce que c'est idiot mais il ya
d'autres choses on en a parlé ici en
disant qu'il y avait des investissements
dans des sociétés qui n'étaient pas
cotées et qui était qui avait besoin
d'argent il y avait il ya des
investissements dans l'or il ya des
investissements dans des actifs réels
que sont l'or le platine l'argent métal
on a des investissements possibles dans
dédé
on l'a dit on a fait une émission aussi
dessus sur les pierres précieuses
on peut faire autre chose que de laisser
un tas de billets dans son dans son
coffre à la banque
ce qui est idiot voilà merci olivier
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous la
semaine prochaine en attendant n'oubliez
pas de poser toutes vos questions à
olivier sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rtk chouan commentaires des
vidéos olivier c'est à vous pour le mot
de la fin est bien encore une fois il
fallait se dire que madame lagarde quand
elle a une idée elle n'est pas forcément
dans le bon sens